Brian Griese kind enough to join us the
college football playoff committees
newest rankings will be revealed Tuesday
exclusively on ESPN at 7:00 Eastern and
Brian's called the Alabama Mississippi
State game on Saturday with Steve Levy
Brian thanks for joining us how when you
saw the injury did you have any idea of
the severity of that yeah and good
morning good to be with you you know I
got to be honest there was a lot going
on and that one particular play you know
there was a lot going on on the sideline
before the play it looked like Mack
Jones the backup quarterback was going
to come in and then it looked like two
went up the code segment and Lobby to
come back into the game just to do that
two-minute drill before half and then
when he got chased down from behind the
first thing we notice was that his head
hit the ground and obviously he was
bleeding from his nose and you really
didn't have a sense as to whether he was
hurt until he tried to stand up and and
put no weight on that on that right leg
and then it was pretty obvious that
there was something significantly wrong
with him we went back and watched the
replay and then you could see where his
knee went into the ground he had two
defenders on his back and there was a
lot of force that went into that knee
and just like we saw with Bo Jackson I
mentioned it during the game when that
when that that leg and it gets jammed
back into the hip good things don't
happen and I gotta be honest and it was
it was probably one of the worst games
I've ever called as an announcer just
because you hate to see the young
players young men like that get hurt in
that fashion and you know the severity
of that injury and it could be
threatening to his future career there's
no question what do we know about that
injury aside from bo Jackson and it
ended his career to progress that we've
made
recovery time with something like this
well I don't know if necessarily dan I'm
not the doctor but but what I do know is
you know obviously bo Jackson was a
different kind of athlete than to a
tongue of our lower and played a
different position much like a receiver
they are constantly cutting moving you
know going one direction to another I
think a quarterback certainly has a
better opportunity of coming back from
an injury like this because they're in
the pocket and who was moving around but
he's not making those hard cuts so I
hope I know this that the kid will will
have the surgery and he will rehab and
he's a determined young man and he'll do
everything he needs to get back on the
football field and I think I think he
will I don't think there was any
question that he'll get back and he will
and he'll give himself an opportunity to
play at the next level at some point we
love to blame somebody we're a
results-based sport society but if
you're looking at this can you put blame
on anybody and if so who I don't think
so Dan I mean you know we we talked
about it during the broadcast
if it were me if I were Nick Saban I
don't think I would have started to a
target of our lower in that game I don't
think they needed to to win the game
they had an opportunity to start max
Jones and to Akane out and he warmed up
pregame and if you needed him for
whatever reason if it didn't go well in
the first half with back Jones you could
always bring Tula in start of the second
quarter start of the second half if you
needed him but that's not the way that
that next day that operates it's about
the way he decided to go and then like
he said listen once the guys cleared to
play I'm not coaching the game based on
thinking a guy could get injured and I
understand that but at the same time you
got a you have to assume the risk up
thirty five seven right before half it
seemed like he wanted to take him out
and he got talked into him going back
out on the field and unfortunately this
happened where did you have him ranked
among the quarterbacks draft eligible
quarterbacks
yeah that's a good question you know I
work with Todd mache he's on my crew as
well we talked quite a bit about this on
a weekly basis Todd had him ranked
number one out of the quarterbacks I did
not I think there's a couple of
quarterbacks that that I would take
would have taken a head of too uh but I
but I think obviously he's a first-round
talent he's a special individual and and
you have every opportunity to to be
successful at the next level we're
talking to Brian Griese espn/abc college
football analyst he was on the call with
Steve Levy Alabama and Mississippi State
also Molly McGrath who did a wonderful
job there on the sidelines I mean that
that's that's where you know you kind of
go into reporter mode and you know she
gave us up close and personal view of
that injury and how painful it was for
to us so please send our best to her she
was wonderful Saturday in dealing with a
tragic injury there I'm also curious
about this though Brian with the
evolution of the quarterbacking position
everybody's getting caught up with the
evolution first it was Patrick mahomes
who changed the NFL now apparently Lamar
Jackson is changing the NFL are they
changing the NFL or are they changing
the people the establishment in opening
their eyes to the possibility of who can
play and what type of player can play
that position well I definitely think
that they're they're changing the
decision-makers minds right that's all
that really matters the people that are
going to select you in the draft a and B
coach you at the next level and their
job going to be on the line based on how
you play so the fact that that John
Harbaugh put all of his eggs in Lamar
Jackson basket in sending tobacco
packing I think that that's what you
need as as a player and as a what is
becoming a transformational player in
the large axis you need to convince one
person and that person is the one that
job is on the line whether you play well
or not and and so he has every every
face of John Harbaugh I think he owes a
little bit yes to the Michael Vick's of
the world that that came into the league
and did it a different way and it's it's
fun to watch right now I think defenses
are on their heels
now what it'll remain to be seen if you
can sustain this right if Tyler Murray
can sustain this can they stay healthy
right that's that's the biggest question
that everybody brings up because you
don't have a backup you don't have a
transformational player back at these
guys up that can do the same kinds of
things so to me I think it's good for
the league I think diversity and
offensive attacks is great I think
putting defenses and defensive
coordinators and soft positions it is
awesome so it's a lot of fun to watch
it's a lot of fun to call and I think
you're gonna get more and more of these
stuff kinds of players coming out of
college because there's a lot of them
that are gonna get a chance Brian is on
the call tonight it'll be on Westwood
one with the Chiefs and Chargers from
Mexico City more likely to have an NFL
team in Mexico or London first Dean
Spanos is not going anywhere
so I would say neither okay I tell you
just one just walking around down here
you know there's 29 million people in
the city of Mexico City and you see a
lot of Patrick mahomes jerseys the
approach is working I have seen quite a
few charges jerseys as well oh the
people down here the people down here
love it you know I went to dinner last
night and you know they got the the
Bears Rams game on there they're not
watching soccer they're watching a fell
football or curtain like talk to my
woman in Spanish Dan yes I did talk to
him in Spanish about his favorite team
and evidently he's a Steelers fan so you
know American football is very popular
down here it's but it's not the kind of
spend a few days and and see the game
how they see it
and I know they're excited about the
game tonight will you speak Spanish
tonight on the broadcast oh I think I'm
gonna have to give me a little taste
as soon keep away she's single lugar de
mas must worth paying or facing football
I don't know what you said but it sounds
like it was Chiefs Chargers and maybe
some good football or something like
that if I said you could have lamar
jackson or patrick mahomes moving
forward who does Brian Griese have Wow
it I don't think anybody could pass up
Patrick Holmes I mean as transcended a
player and talent naturally as Lamar
Jackson is that's as good a thrower and
quarterback as Patrick Holmes's and the
only reason I say this is because of
that injury question you're much more
likely to stay healthy if you're Patrick
mahomes to go for the pockets then you
are Lamar Jackson running running
downfield and that's that's maybe the
only reason why I would I would say that
Bryan have fun tonight
when you see Steve Lee we give our best
to leaves and we'll be listening thank
you thank you
that's Brian Griese espn/abc college
football analyst and on the call for
Westwood One tonight Chargers sheet
Chargers Chiefs from Mexico City for
more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on be our live or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]